c'est la révélation est mbappé qui
viennent fêter ses vingt des vingt ans
pardon peut-être j'ai lu un article plus
grands joueurs de le prochain le plus
grand joueur de l'histoire
tu connais pas grand-chose en foot mais
je trouve très très sympathique et la
figure et vous que guillaume a un avis
sur m
tous un génial alors on s'est engueulés
hier parce que vous étiez là je
comprends que tu dis ça ce garçon est
humble il est simple on a tendance à
dire que les footeux on a le souvenir de
la vieille génération des footeux les
anelka les machins qui gueulait qui
tapait qui était grossier il est humble
il est gentil reverse une partie de 2
comment dire de ces primes de ses
cachets 1 et de ces primes à des
associations totalité mamie ouais enfin
c'est juste un mec génial quoi bravo
bravo et c'est bien qu'on ait ce garçon
et en plus il joue il joue à paris bravo
c'est très bien vous rachel weisz et ce
jusqu'à ce pas de secret vous sortez
avec un jour de foot benjamin pas marc
est un champion du monde de surcroît est
ce que du coup vous l'avez voulu vous
rencontrez un peu ses potes vous l'avez
rencontré deux maps est très discret non
mais ça je m'en fous c'est quand tu te
rends compte il est aussi discret dans
la vie ça a été très discret ouais j'ai
l'impression en tout cas les discrets
d'accord je connais pas personnellement
non mais tu confirmes que c'est
quelqu'un avait placé vous je crois
qu'il est célibataire encore je ne crois
pas qu'il soit de deux côtés du terrain
du même côté du terrain
de l'équipe adverse de l'équipe adverse
sinon natura pour une passe deux mois
encore mais catherine ce qu'est ce qui
dérangeait avec les précédents
footballeur cette génération qui a été
si décriée d'en parler guillaume c'est
qu'il n'avait pas la reconnaissance de
ce que la france qui les prend les
formes quand même avec nos deniers
c'est une formation public il y avait
une espèce de mépris pour la france sans
que lui les hypers respectueux hyper
souriant hyper le bienveillant enfin
mais il a toutes les qualités qu'on
attend d'un footballeur qui représente
la france qu'on n'avait pas les
précédents mais je pense que le
comparatif il est surtout très
talentueux et surtout la gagner ils ont
gagné la coupe du monde donc ça voilà
mais c'est vrai c'est absolument vrai
que c'est fini un peu plus que tu lisais
les anelka les cantona des joueurs que
tendance est parfois un petit peu vieux
mais c'est très agréable qu'on associe
plus forcément le foot ces jeunes
parfois à l'appel la violence un peu
racaille tout ça mais au contraire à des
jolies valeur